learning is so central to everything
human beings do
knowledge needs to be absorbed by people
who need it knowledge is a great enabler
this is what we are the mission of open
learning is to share knowledge
we want to make sure that learning isn't
this thing we keep but
people can take and do something with it
for their lives for their enjoyment for
the fulfillment of their ambitions their
dreams
so we work with mit faculty and we bring
content to the world
we are doing research on the science of
learning about how to actually teach
regardless of whether you're online or
in person
how do memories form how do neurons work
how does context impact our learning
what we have is a very very rich
community rich in terms of talent rich
in terms of diversity of thought
diversity of background diversity of
purpose
it's a glorious thing open learning's
values have a lot to do with the word
open
we have to open education we have to
open learning
mit's vision is that learning has to be
free and liberated
in the sense that anyone can access it
it's got to be efficient so people can
access it in a way that's most effective
some of those things you can do better
online
and some things like coaching or
mentoring you can do better in person
[Music]
the pandemic has taught us that the
half-life of knowledge is even shorter
than it was before
jobs are changing media has changed
entire industries have changed
that means that human beings are going
to have to transform themselves and the
oxygen for that is learning
there's so much we don't know and so
much we can do better so i think this is
the beginning of an incredible journey